merci rachète mal de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes sénateurs du Val-d'Oise c'est
mateur socialiste du val-d'oasis
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées on va parler de l'actualité mais
l'actualité elle est dominée et
évidemment par l'attaque à Nancy attaque
au couteau contre des enfants avant
d'entendre votre réaction on va aller
tout de suite à Annecy retrouver Julien
il se transgen bonjour Julien merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeur de
l'édition de Haute-Savoie du Dauphiné
Libéré Julien évidemment ce matin dans
votre journal de longue page et de
nombreux témoignages sur ce drame oui on
consacre 6 pages à ce drame d'Annecy qui
s'est déroulé donc hier matin
provoquant une énorme émotion en ville
c'est avec M6 une ville qui est
relativement tranquille habituellement
on attaque l'été le festival du cinéma
d'animation débutant quelques jours bref
rien ne laissait présager ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé hier en plein
centre-ville parce que c'est vraiment
pour ceux qui connaissent pas M6 c'est
vraiment un lieu qui est à
l'hypercenterie à quelques dizaines
quelques mètres de la mairie quelques
centaines de mètres de la préfecture sur
le paquet un lieu qui est prisé des
années siens qui est prise et des
touristes ou les enfants se promènent ou
les enfants jouent bref c'est le dernier
lieu on attendait qu'il se passe une
attaque aussi dramatique et qui s'est
déroulée tôt hier matin un tout petit
peu avant 9h hier matin et Julien vous
avez des questions sur ce sujet par la
suite
bonjour on l'a vu dans le reportage de
mes confrères juste avant il y a
immédiatement une forme de récupération
dans tous les sens de ce de ce drame un
député d'automne ou disait la
récupération est venue avant même que
les victimes soient arrivées à l'hôpital
ce qui est absolument terrible qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de la manière dont
justement le débat c'est immédiatement
porté sur la question de l'immigration
avant même qu'on sache ce qui s'est
réellement passé hier et d'ailleurs on
sait encore toujours pas quels sont les
motivations du du de la saillant d'abord
pour répondre à avant de répondre à
votre question je dis d'abord dire pour
moi c'est une forme de barbarie si on
prend des enfants des poussettes cette
fin de barbarie et moi je pense d'abord
et avant tout aux familles mais aussi
tous les personnes qui sont intervenus
que soit les policiers les pompiers etc
parce que c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui
je crois le moment dans lequel nous
vivons ensuite sur la récupération moi
je la condamne je la condamne parce que
encore une fois personne c'est vraiment
ce qui s'est passé j'ai entendu
la nationalité de la personne puis
finalement on a parlé de religion pour
ça puis finalement les gens sont dit
c'est pas la bonne religion je crois
faut laisser l'enquête voilà c'est un
drame c'est une forme de barbarie que
nous vivons que nous avons vécu moi je
connais le lieu parce que je me suis
déjà rendu Annecy joue après où cela est
j'imagine le choc pour les pour les
familles j'entendais tout à l'heure à la
radio des familles qui viennent
régulièrement et donc dire est-ce que je
vais pouvoir revenir avec mes enfants
donc il faut je crois laisser cette
partie là et laisser les Français vivre
cela et je crois que encore une fois
l'utilisation politique de certains est
scandaleuse totalement scandaleuse j'ai
joué la condamne
j'ai vu notamment l'extrême droite même
madame berger très honnêtement expliqué
qu'on peut pas légiférer parce qu'il y a
un drame madame berger il y a le drame
aussi de par le monde
qui est mine de silence qui a un moment
on arrête on puisse arrêter quelques
instants les débats etc mais le monde
peut pas s'arrêter malheureusement je le
dis pas s'arrêter et dire parce que il y
a ce drame là qui touche des enfants qui
sont en situation encore on se parle
dans une situation critique on peut pas
légiférer sur tel ou tel texte ce n'est
pas sérieux nous sommes en démocratie la
démocratie plus fort que tout le reste
parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'à chaque
fois quelqu'un veut être un débat il se
passe un incident bon faut être un peu
sérieux pour descendre faut penser aux
familles faut espérer surtout que les
enfants sortent de la situation de
l'État crise dans lequel ils sont parce
que c'est des enfants quand même voilà
et puis et puis il faut reprendre la vie
mais surtout de pas basculer dans ni la
récupération ni les propos j'ai envie de
dire de comptoir quand j'entends
certains dire qu'il faut empêcher la
circulation en Europe très honnêtement
on va arrêter de dire que les gens peut
se déplacer dans les pays de l'Union
européenne tout ça n'est pas sérieux et
justement Julien a une question
là-dessus justement par rapport à la
circulation la libre circulation des
citoyens à l'intérieur de l'Union elle
est une elle est une réalité est-ce que
néanmoins vous pensez que dans le cas de
ces demandeurs d'asile il faudrait qu'il
y ait une sorte d'ajustement puisque il
était en situation régulière en France
du fait qu'il était en situation
régulière en Suède où il avait obtenu
l'asile si en tout cas l'enquête telle
qu'elle est faite aujourd'hui
se base sur des faits qui sont avéré la
maison il semblerait que ce soit le cas
est-ce que vous pensez à la demandeur
d'asile il faudrait quand même une
nuance dans la libre circulation entre
les pays de l'Union européenne mais là
on évoque des ce qui ce qui est au cœur
du projet européen je rappelle que dans
le proche européen ce qui a été dans la
clinique de 4986 c'est la liberté de
circulation des biens et des personnes
dire soit on dit on remet en cause
totalement la construction européenne il
faut l'assumer ou c'est pas la position
donc la tunique puis après il y a eu
Schengen etc etc d'ailleurs sodas tout
ce corps là qui a fond qui fonde
aujourd'hui nous européenne la personne
d'après ce que encore une fois je sais à
ce stade comme tout le monde j'en sais
pas beaucoup plus que ce qu'a dit le
ministre notamment de l'Intérieur hier
soir la personne est en situation
régulière donc elle a le droit comme
tous les membres de l'Union européenne
de se déplacer c'est-à-dire que on
devrait dire sinon imaginons après ce
que ce qu'on est en train de dire pour
que chacun ait bien sans tête c'est que
on dirait quand vous êtes de nationalité
française allemande suédois enfin tout
ce que vous voulez vous pouvez vous
déplacer
et on va créer une nouvelle douane
puisque quand vous n'êtes pas de
nationalité mais vous avez un titre de
séjour en situation régulière régulière
vous ne pouvez pas vous déplacer donc on
va créer une douane entre les 20 tous
les pays de l'Union européenne pour dire
aux gens bon bonjour on doit vérifier le
papier enfin il faut aussi vraiment
arrêter de mentir aux Français et
arrêter dans ce débat du Concours Lépine
de la bonne idée voilà donc on sait qu'à
la fin c'est terrible idée bon donc soit
on dit on remet des frontières et on
finit notre histoire il faut autre chose
soit effectivement c'est une personne
qui est qui est en situation régulière
après on va me dire oui mais alors les
frontières extérieures moi je suis pour
que des frontières extérieures soient
totalement hermétique
on vérifiera si cela est possible
hermétique mais vous voyez bien que
c'est pas là aujourd'hui c'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est une personne dont
on y a une ce matin je crois encore une
étude psychiatrique donc personne
connaît la situation exacte voilà donc
une personne connaît ni les ressorts
psychiatriques ni les raisons il
semblerait qu'elle est autonomie des
propos il y a une religion au moment de
l'Inde mais il semblerait puisque tout
ça n'est pas confirmé voilà je propose
qu'on fasse d'abord l'enquête et qu'à
partir d'enquête on est potentiellement
des conclusions peut-être
potentiellement des évolutions mais là
il faut dans ce débat là au milieu de ça
ça me paraît un peu dangereux même pour
nos démocraties merci beaucoup Julien
merci d'avoir été avec nous évidemment
édition spéciale ce matin à lire dans Le
Dauphiné Libéré les froid à la une du
Dauphiné Libéré merci beaucoup Julien
Estrangin d'avoir été avec nous on en
parlait un petit peu avec Julien mais
cette attaque à la résonné jusque dans
l'hémicycle du Parlement minime de
silence à l'Assemblée au Sénat mais
l'assemblée qui examinait au même moment
la proposition de loi du groupe liotte
qui visait à abroger les 64 ans le texte
a été vidé de sa substance est-ce que
l'iode a eu raison de le retirer hier
matin
[Musique]
moi et je crois que ça il faut pas du
coup ça va avoir des conséquences pour
vous sur le travail parlementaire sur
les relations entre Parlement exécutives
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours
oui bah oui comme je l'ai dit
que finalement est-ce que la présidente
de l'Assemblée
nationale ou être la courroie de
transmission du gouvernement ça c'est
une question totale parce que c'est
comme le disait dans notre République
enfin là c'est pas son pouvoir c'est
vieux comme la Révolution française les
mêmes avant avec le siècle des Lumières
c'est c'est un principe fondamental là
séparation des pouvoirs et quand il y a
plus de séparation des pouvoirs alors
nous avons un problème de de
fonctionnement d'une démocratie est-ce
que la bataille politique elle est
perdue pour vous sur la réforme des
retraites non parce que vous savez la
réalité c'est pas la bataille politique
l'arrêter c'est ce que vivent les gens
et aujourd'hui quand vous parlez avec
les Français comme chacun tout le monde
condamne dans la majorité vous avez
toutes les études condamnent ces deux
ans de plus ces deux années ce qu'on
leur prend de de retraite donc je pense
que l'engagement la gauche c'est de dire
que cette loi sera abrogée et puis après
il faudra faire une réforme alors
votre campagne bien sûr j'entendais
monsieur du socle dire qui est pas de
projet s'il y a des projets alternatifs
il y en a plein donc il ne peut pas
mentir moi je veux dire ma position
personnelle qui n'engage que moi je
pense qu'un système d'une logique où une
sorte de points système de points qui
permettrait d'intégrer la pénibilité
s'il y a des métiers ils partirent à 55
ans et d'autres plus tard pas être un
modèle qui sera aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus performant que celui-là bête et
méchant ou finalement dans le projet du
gouvernement plus vous êtes dans une
catégorie sociale peu élevée avec des
métiers plus durs et peu payés plus
votre retraite est plus dur et vous
aurez moins grande retraite c'est un
vrai problème entre pays on va parler du
fond Marianne il y a eu des
rebondissements cette semaine dans
l'affaire du fond Marianne vous avez
poussé vous pour une commission
d'enquête au Sénat puisque ce fond avait
été créé après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty dans votre département la
commission d'enquête a poursuivi cette
travaux on va faire le résumé de cette
semaine avec Quentin calmé
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane Bonjour
architecte mal bonjour et Quentin une
nouvelle semaine cruciale dans le
travail de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat sur le fond Marianne voilà on peut
même parler d'accélération des travaux
et dire aussi qu'on commence un peu à
recoller les morceaux du puzzle autour
de ce fond Marianne et à comprendre en
fait l'intrigue de l'enquête pour rappel
ce fond lancée par Marlène Schiappa en
2021 ce sont 2,7 millions d'euros
distribués à des associations pour
lutter contre la radicalisation en ligne
après l'assassinat terrible de Samuel
Paty sur le gris sénatorial cette
semaine mercredi c'est au tour de
l'ancien directeur de cabinet de Marlène
Schiappa actuel préfet de l'Orne une
audition tendue on peut le dire très
longue et des sénateurs qui n'ont pas
hésité à revenir plusieurs fois sur
certaines questions sur certains sujets
pour et bien éclaircir toutes les
informations jusqu'à même ce que le
préfet se sentent comme acculés
écoutaient cet extrait
on est sur des questions qui sont
extrêmement précises et je l'entends
qu'il faut aussi une information
judiciaire
financier vous modifiez dans un cadre
qui est différent avec des questions qui
sont extrêmement précises sur lesquels
je n'ai pas avec moi les éléments de
documentation qui me serait nécessaire
je n'ai pas non plus d'un avocat il me
paraît délicat d'être dans cet exercice
qui est légitime et auquel je me donne
complètement sans avoir des garanties
minimales de défense et de protection
une audition le préfet également fait
quelques révélations Quentin voilà le
préfet a raconté en fait comment c'est
passé le processus de désignation des
associations bénéficiaires du fond
Marianne il expliquait avoir je cite
rendu compte à Marlène Schiappa de la
liste des lauréats et que sur une
association la ministre a eu une réserve
je cite toujours en raison d'un
historique assez ancien c'est ce qu'a
dit donc cet ancien collaborateur de
Marlène Schiappa il s'agit en fait
racheté mal de l'association SOS Racisme
en conflit ouvert à ce moment-là dans la
presse avec la secrétaire d'État
résultat l'association va se voir privé
à l'époque de 100.000 euros de
subvention pour les sénateurs c'est
problématique écouter hier le président
de cette commission d'enquête à notre
micro
un ministre puisse avoir son mot à dire
sur des propositions de subventions qui
sont faites par un problème c'est pas le
sujet en soi ce qui est le sujet c'est
que Marine jappa a toujours dit qu'elle
n'avait pas participé à ce choix voilà
donc là il y a une contradiction est-ce
que entre ce qu'elle a toujours dit et
la réalité on ne le dites
je vous laisse le voilà on va
l'interroger et lorsque nous l'aurons
interrogé nous verrons bien ce qu'il
dira sincèrement effectivement rien ne
ce n'est pas ce qui avait dit la
secrétaire d'État dans les médias
écoutez malencia pas sur ce même plateau
d'ailleurs c'était fin avril
j'ai pas choisi les associations et je
veux démentir aussi quelque chose qui a
été dit notamment par certains
responsables et les filles qui ont dit
que j'allais donner de l'argent à mes
amis qui avaient du copinage ou du
favoritisme je ne suis amie avec aucun
lauréat du fond de Marianne aucun par un
pas un et mon proche ni personnellement
ni associer ni que sais-je contrairement
à ce que j'ai lu eux-mêmes l'ont démenti
mais après vous voyez à quel point ces
accusations sont difficiles à démentir
dernier mot dans l'audition de mercredi
l'ancien directeur de cabinet a même
expliqué que des membres de l'équipe de
Marlène Schiappa ont bien sollicité
certaines associations dont celle de
Mohamed Sifaoui principal bénéficiaire
du fond Marianne qui est un intellectuel
qui est membre du printemps républicain
il y a bien eu une volonté du cabinet de
la ministre de pouvoir décider valider
l'emploi des crédits un revendiquer
l'ancien directeur de cabinet de Marlène
Schiappa nous verrons maintenant ce que
dira l'ancienne secrétaire d'État en
charge du fond Marianne au Sénat elle
est parmi les dernières auditionnées
dans cette commission d'enquête et elle
est convoquée par la commission mercredi
matin à à 10h
Rachida a-t-elle menti dans les médias
alors d'abord
moi j'ai plus de liberté de ton et de
parole que le président rénal que je
salue et aussi avec son rapporteur
Husson qui font un énorme travail
effectivement j'avais demandé une
commission enquête et c'est très bien
qu'elle existe il faut saluer aussi le
travail des médias qui en amont c'est
grâce à au travail d'un cendres
collègues on a pu vocal et France
Télévisions sur le sujet il faut le dire
ensuite une fois qu'on s'est dit ça
manifestement soit la ministrement de
cabinet puisque vous avez passé deux
extraits il y a manifestement une vision
différente des deux bon ce qui est dans
cette affaire là encore une fois entre
vous avez des gens qui ont été choisis
en amont par le cabinet de Madame
Schiappa déjà ça c'est problématique
on fait un appel à projet et avoir un
appel à projet des gens à pleines viens
puisque on va faire un truc bon moi j'ai
regardé aussi les auditions notamment
des directeurs et directrices de de
enfin des responsables associatifs
voilà donc autant dire que à l'oral ils
m'ont pas convaincu il y a écrit mais
justement c'était un simple A4 un recto
pour avoir 300000 euros ils n'ont pas
convaincu manifestement grand monde et
puis après vous avez un problème qui est
dire la ministre elle prend un arbitrage
contrairement à ce qu'elle a toujours
dit mais après c'est aussi les raisons
de l'arbitrage qu'elle dit cette
association a pose problème parce que je
sais pas quoi parce que mauvaise gestion
parce que ceci parce que cela externe
aussi moins Marlène Schiappa je
m'entends pas bien avec eux ou je ne
sais quoi c'est enfin nous démarcher de
droit divin donc dans tout ça pose
d'énormes questions d'un problème il se
rappelont aussi qui a le rapport
d'inspection en général l'administration
ça fait beaucoup de choses qui a
provoqué la démission du préfet Gravel
qui était le secrétaire général du CPL
qui contrôlait le fond Marianne qui
contrôlait manifestement moins que l'on
le pense mais en tout cas ce qui est
clair c'est que il faut laisser la
commission enquête c'est à moi je le
redis le Parlement c'est faire la loi
l'évaluation de petit public mais c'est
aussi contrôler l'action du gouvernement
c'est dans la caution et encore une fois
on peut être fier que le Sénat joue
pleinement son rôle et encore une fois
bravo à nos collègues qui sont dans
cette commission d'enquête ils mènent un
travail important et je crois nécessaire
dans une démocratie
une dernière question qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de l'audition de Marlène je
sais pas mercredi et est-ce que vous
entendez aussi beaucoup de choses de
Mohamed cifaoui vous le connaissez
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
personnage moi
j'ai eu un débat dans le il était pardon
il était responsable éditorial de la
principale association bénéficiaire du
fond Marianne moi j'ai eu un débat sur
je passe une autre chaîne mais on a eu
un débat sur Marianne c'est une chaîne
qui émet 24/24 et ça se termine avec un
V à la fin bon chacun trouvera mais on a
eu un débat et il a dit très clairement
sur le plateau donc c'est tout le monde
peut retrouver ça il l'a dit très
clairement à l'antenne dans le débat que
j'avais avec lui que il avait été appelé
par le cabinet de manchapa pour venir
dans les dispositif voilà donc moi j'ai
attendu qui redise ce qui ce qu'elle a
dit la vérité et qu'ensuite on aura
écouté madame Chapat pour nous expliquer
comment elle dit un jour qu'elle n'a pas
participé sans dire qu'à dit qu'elle a
participé elle dit qu'elle connaît
personne et des gens disent son cabinet
m'a appelé dire ça elle de nous
expliquer la suite des opérations merci
je suis content on suivra ça la semaine
prochaine absolument compter sur nous ce
sera évidemment et vous revenez donc
du drame dance ici ensemble ce sera
évidemment à suivre oh merci Quentin
tout de suite on parle de la loi de
programmation militaire puisque c'est un
sujet que vous suivez évidemment j'étais
mal Assemblée nationale qu'il a adopté
très largement cette semaine cette loi
qui on le rappelle augmente le budget
des armées qui prévoit 413 milliards
d'euros sur 7 ans pour financer nos
armées vous avez auditionné mercredi
Sébastien encore nuit ministre des
Armées est-ce qu'il vous a convaincu
est-ce que vous allez voter ce texte
alors je voudrais alors je retourne
beaucoup de gens je sais pas beaucoup de
temps mais les 413 vous verrez que dans
le débat c'est un peu plus court un peu
plus
avec la loi de programmation militaire
actuellement
plus l'inflation 30000 mais c'est pas le
sujet j'ai envie de dire non nous ce
qu'on va dire ce qu'on a dit au ministre
d'abord il y a un premier sujet c'est
que nous l'actuel loi de programmation
mitter dans lequel nous sommes qu'ils
veste amenés en 2025 n'a pas été évalué
et nous considérons là aussi c'est un
rôle du Parlement de dire le
gouvernement c'est opposé deuxième chose
sur le rôle du Parlement est-ce que vous
avez eu des garanties vous demandez plus
de contrôle parlementaires
il y a une base c'est-à-dire quand vous
faites une boîte programmation militaire
c'est-à-dire jusqu'en 2030 c'est que
vous imaginez quels sont les défis
potentiels en termes de sécurité sous
toutes ses formes soit dans les fonds
marins jusqu'à la CBA l'espace de cyber
les conventionnelles et je pourrais en
passer beaucoup d'autres ça et donc
quelle menace que tu menace ça ça n'a
pas le Parlement n'a pas été associé et
je trouve que c'est regrettable parce
que il y a un vrai débat de fond et une
fois que j'ai dit ça la position des
socialistes parce que nous sommes aussi
dans une tradition dans une construction
que ce soit François Mitterrand Lionel
Jospin ou François Hollande la les
socialiste ont toujours été là-dessus
totalement d'équerre sur la nécessité de
défendre et d'importer des sécurités à
notre pays à nos concitoyens qui soit
partout dans le monde et donc nous
allons nous les socialistes bonifier
cette cette loi et donc nous avons des
amendements pour améliorer les choses
que soit le contrôle mais pas seulement
il y a un certain nombre de choses qu'on
va vous lister si vous voulez mais je
crois que j'ai pas beaucoup de temps
comment il faut la bonifier d'abord il y
a des aspects budgétaires il y a des
aspects aussi je l'ai dit on va dire de
stratégie les aspects capacités il y a
des aspects sur un ensemble de domaines
ciblés etc et puis il y a aussi le
contrôle du Parlement donc ça fait
beaucoup de choses que nous allons
proposer mais nous ne serons pas dans
une logique de changer de virgule ou
sans logique de encore une fois
bonification d'amélioration sensible de
cette loi après je crois qu'il sera il
sera bon après la prochaine élection
présidentielle d'avoir à nouveau
certains passent d'une revue stratégique
d'un livre blanc en tout cas d'avoir un
vrai débat parce que je crois que le
temps dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui et on le voit que c'est pas
son Ukraine on a pensé pendant très
longtemps mais tout le monde confondu
qu'on nous étions dans la fin de
l'histoire les dividendes de la paix et
que la paix serait pour toujours en fait
dans le monde quand vous regardez
l'histoire dans un long terme il y a
plus de temps de guerre ouverte ou
diffuse que de paix et donc je crois
qu'il faut qu'on se retrouve aussi en
France dans cette logique globalement et
pas seulement les forces armées et le
pays c'est que la sécurité est il faut
qu'on il faut mettre des moyens il faut
parce qu'il y a des défis majeurs et
donc je crois que c'est là dessus faudra
travailler donc fois c'est l'ensemble du
pays c'est le rapport entre l'État la
France la nation ces armée c'est moins
une défense c'est moins de sécurité
c'est moins financier pour aboutir voilà
et puis il y a aussi un autre élément si
je peux terminer c'est que à partir du
moment où on fait le choix le
gouvernement le dit de maintenir en gros
l'armée telle que nous la connaissons en
termes capacité à se dire en gros une
armée qui a de tout mais en peu nombre
bon se pose alors la question de comment
on emmène des opérations conséquentes
alors la question des alliances et donc
du rôle de la France dans l'OTAN dans
l'OTAN se pose et puis avec un volet
européen ouais toutes ces questions là
ils ne sont pas je trouve assez
tranchées
vous êtes obligé de d'avoir des autres
coopérations plus fortes avec le temps
aujourd'hui nous avons réintégrer le
campement pour intégrer le temps il y a
un amendement sur un bilan et je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose mais moi je
crois qu'il faut aller plus loin je
crois qu'il faut s'admer plus fortement
notre rôle dans le temps prendre des
positions leaders prendre des
discussions notamment je prends sur les
discussions nucléaire il y a des
éléments il y a des clubs etc je crois
qu'il faut être plus fort parce que je
crois que c'est comme cela que nous
pourrons construire avec dans l'OTAN
avec nos partenaires des vraies
stratégies communes parce que la
question qui sera posée peut-être dans
quelques années c'est s'il y a un
conflit plus ou moins ouvert sur l'Indo
Pacifique en gros entre la Chine et
l'Amérique bien sûr nous avons un rôle à
jouer nous parce que nous avons la
Nouvelle-Calédonie l'Indo-Pacifique nous
avons des terres le la Polynésie le
volcanique etc mais ça veut dire que sur
le flanc européen face à la Russie il
faut des troupes armée il faut donc les
Européens plus monter en puissance si
jamais avait un conflit
des heures mais
malheureusement
et cette loi de programmation militaire
dans les missiles qu'on en parlera
évidemment à ce moment-là sénatorial
vous êtes candidat dans le Val-d'Oise
mais vous n'avez pas réussi à faire
l'union de la gauche vous le regrettez
nous avons tout nous proposons
là où nous en sommes il y a d'abord une
discussion nationale le Parti socialiste
nationalement moi je demande de la
Commission électorale discute avec avec
le parti avec le Parti communiste
français et Europe Écologie Les Verts
nous en sommes là
ensuite nous avons nous avons je dis pas
qu'il y a pas de discussion parce que
les parties se parlent bon mais en tout
cas négociation dans lequel nous
travaillons et les simulations
nationalement c'est avec c'est avec les
deux parties que je vous indiquais le
Parti communiste français europécologie
les Verts et ensuite tu auras des
déclinaisons par département voilà donc
mais en tout cas dans le département du
Val-d'Oise pour aller jusqu'au bout de
question en 2017 nous avions proposé à
ces deux formations politiques d'avoir
une alliance nous leur proposons là et
bien il y a aussi beaucoup de divers
gauche
dans mon département comme ailleurs et
donc c'est aussi un électorat très
important et des communes qu'il faut
représenter pour qu'il faut travailler
mais vous savez que sénateur on
travaille pour l'ensemble des communes
moi j'en ai 84 qu'en ce moment nous
sommes en bataille pour obtenir enfin un
lycée à Magny-en-Vexin je le fais avec
tous les élus quel que soit leur
étiquette quand je pose une loi que je
l'ai fait là pour avoir sur Roissy horly
et le Bourget un couvre-feu et un
plafonnement des vols je le fais
également avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus et quel que soit les
humeurs que leurs petites dorée un
parlementaire un sénateur en tout cas il
doit fédérer pour des projets pour son
territoire un mot sur ce qui se passe du
côté du Parti socialiste et de la Fronde
peut-être au sein du Parti socialiste
vous allez nous le dire puisque demain
Bernard Cazeneuve qui a quitté le PS
l'ange son mouvement avec une partie du
Parti socialiste qui sera présent
notamment François Hollande est-ce que
vous irez vous au lancement de ce
mouvement je ne serai pas demain
avec Bernard cazenchanges avec Bernard
comme avec beaucoup d'autres personnes
c'est moi je crois que quand on veut
gagner il y a plusieurs conditions
d'abord quand on est socialiste en tout
cas d'abord il faut savoir réunir la
famille sociale et je dis la famille
socialiste beaucoup sont dans les murs
d'autres en dehors des murs il faudra
amener rassembler l'ensemble de la
famille et puis puis rassembler
l'ensemble de la gauche et après
l'ensemble des Français défunt dépasser
aussi nos simples frontières donc
Bernard Cazeneuve comme d'autres ont une
volonté de d'apporter un renouveau
idéologique je crois que c'est
nécessaire à la famille politique à ma
famille politique je suis moi je m'en
félicite tout seul et tous ceux qui sont
dans ce dans ce proche là moi je
soutiens toutes les démarches dans le
ici comme en dehors du parti et
l'essentiel encore une fois c'est d'un
projet politique qui change la vie des
gens parce que à la fin on l'a vu tout à
l'heure sur les retraites ou sur
d'autres sujets c'est surtout les
Français vous avez vu un rapport qui est
sorti hier sur l'Observatoire des
inégalités elle se creuse encore en
France est-ce que vous souhaitez que
cette gauche qu'on va appeler en tenue
pour la simplifier sur cette approche là
il y a pas la gauche nue et la coupe
anti-up il y a la gauche qui critique
l'orientation de les efforts sur le fait
que la France insoumise il y a eu un
Congo partialiste il y a eu des
résultats il y a 55 ans voilà Olivier
forêt de nouveau premier secrétaire avec
deux secrétaires délégués il a une
Geoffroy est présent du Conseil national
on va pas revenir sur le passé moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est comment le Parti
socialiste prépare la les sénatoriales
pour que notre objectif c'est que nous
ayons collectivement PS PC
50 50
c'est que 1/2 à voter pour l'huile
d'oliveur un sur deux voté pour la ligne
soit Nicolas merciel soit de Geoffroy
donc non ça s'appelle la démocratie
respecte votre ce que je vous dis par là
c'est que nous le spatialiste doit
préparer les natoyages que nous faisons
de préparer les européennes parce qu'il
y a aussi un enjeu pas en France aussi
mais surtout en Europe comment on change
la majorité de droite au Parlement
européen pourra des politiques de gauche
au niveau européen et il y aura la
présidentielle mais state basse-tête et
j'ai envie de dire et c'est à partir du
Parti socialiste que moi je souhaite
qu'il y ait une reconstruction de la
gauche et une victoire des prochaines
aux prochaines élections merci rachète
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin